i got the most votes in new york state
for libertarian ever we had never made
been an official party in 50 years how
did i do that it wasn't by using any of
this rhetoric it was by creating actual
solutions that both sides could accept
right so one of the things i talk about
is the mta in new york city is a
disaster and my nose you see it's
horrible right so one of my answers was
why don't we lease out naming rights to
bridges there are a dozen bridges in new
york city right so why is the george
washington bridge of the verrazano
bridge why isn't the 3m bridge or the
kellogg's bridge or the pepsi bridge or
the google bridge they'll drop a hundred
million dollars on a valuetainment
bridge
we'll get you up on the center side
absolutely right i would actually
understand it 100 and bankers did they
actually came to me in my business world
i'm a business consultant i deal with a
lot of finance people so they were like
this is a good idea larry so we front
loaded 10 year 12 year lease we front
load the cash 100 million dollars up per
year that begins to pay for the bridges
that takes care of maintenance no need
for tolls who pays tolls working poor
middle-class pace tools the wealthy
nukes that are live in new york city so
what happens is all of a sudden we get a
solution and the wealthy pay more which
is what the left wants but there's no
extra taxes so it's what the right wants
the left and the right are both
satisfied i've got better bridges more
money coming into my city and the
working poor and the middle class are
taken care of that is what made people
go huh i didn't say i was libertarian i
didn't say i was democrat i didn't say i
was republican i said here's an answer
and people went oh
we're winning as libertarians if the
person in front of me assumes i'm them
and what year was that 2018.
and you're chalking that up to you uh
speaking to the people about issues
correct i think you're wrong tell me
please i'll tell you why i think you
actually were successful
for the exact reason that george
jorgensen was not okay because you're a
charismatic leader it's freaking obvious
you got some some bass in your voice i
like listening to you oh there we go if
you would pat if you still have the
numbers for what gary johnson did in ron
paul and joe jorgensen i'd like to just
recap that because it's so clear what
was wrong with joe jorgensen do you have
those numbers 4.489 joe jorgensen 1.865
and what was ron paul
ron paul well this is jim 431 but ron
paul ran in 88 in the libertarian party
but he got we are now living in a social
media age adam i would tell you i would
i would tell you that some would say
that gary johnson is also the cure for
insomnia
and you know if you know what that means
you know yeah so it's not like that's
exactly a charismatic
nothing against them i would sit there
and i would watch and i'm like
like there was a moment one time with
gary in the 2016. no aleppo no no i'm
just sitting there i'm like give me
yes
sell me something yeah and fire me up
like tell me what we're gonna be doing
that's exactly my point yeah you guys do
not have a messaging problem you guys
aren't gonna bicker over what your
policies are like she might be a policy
wonk you guys need eyeballs you said you
had a popularity problem the only way
like let's be real here if you guys are
trying to get from two percent to five
percent who gives a crap if you're
trying to get from five percent to 25
yep you need popularity you need
eyeballs you need what kanye's here but
brother i don't know if you have that
popularity you need a kanye you need up
next to this guy
right here awesome
that's what you guys so if you like this
clip and you want to watch another one
click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
[Music]